what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I want to jump into the flash
warp real ood flash annual number one
those of you guys who don't know when it
comes to comic books annuals kind of
take different forms we've talked about
this before it used to be that annuals
were just kind of there it was just kind
of like a filler story and it was
usually isolated from everything else
that was going on you would have like a
main story arc and then it would get
around to where we have five weeks in a
month instead of four weeks in a month
there's something weird along those
lines basically like five wednesdays
rather you know as opposed to four and
they just kind of need like a filler
story and so what they do is they just
throw in a random you know annual and
the usually is for like up-and-coming
writers and artists are the ability for
those guys to kind of make their bones
show off what they're capable of and
that kind of a thing but that's really
about it what this does is it actually
kind of breaks that trend which is
something that's been going on for
really a couple decades if we're gonna
be honest with ourselves annuals have
really sort of evolved from like that
old hat format to basically being like
you know tied in to a lot of the ongoing
stories and this one really fleshes out
or at least brings us the pre lute to
flash war of course flash war basically
being an event that's gonna see all the
flashes quote-unquote going to war with
each other but this initially picks up
in the 25th century after the events of
running scared now for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with that running
scared was a story that we did where we
basically dealt with the idea of the
retold origin of eobard thawne of the
reverse-flash in a sense that instead of
him just kind of being a guy who
idolized the flash and then went back
into the past and realize he was
destined to become reverse-flash and it
kind of drove him insane instead it was
the idea that he and Barry shared a very
personal moment when Barry travelled to
the 25th century and met eobard thawne
for the first time and were buried
trained eobard to use his powers and so
on and so forth when eobard went back to
the modern day he saw Barry sharing that
same moment or I guess went back to the
past rather he saw Barry sharing that
same moment with Wally West and the
result was that he felt betrayed and
became a villain but the fact remains
here that in the aftermath of that story
running scared which basically saw iris
West just kind of like dispersing the
atoms of you know eobard thawne all over
the place using some kind of a ray gun
what this did is it set in motion the
idea that people wanted to know what was
going on and what we ended up having was
this group that was basically kind of
tasked with tracking down Barry
basically traveling to the past
tracking down Barry and then
quote-unquote arresting him and this
group was essentially tasked by like a
masked man we didn't really know who he
was but following this we actually kind
of do jump back to the to the modern age
right now and basically pick up with a
guy called
now the top was never a huge character
in the realm of DC Comics he was one of
the small-time guys the overall gist is
that he could basically create like
these massive bursts of wind and spin
things and so on and so forth much like
a top like me like you would expect with
that whole ideology he was a john broom
carmine infantino creation i think but
the whole idea behind this is that he's
just kind of there wreaking havoc and
then that's really about it and the
result is that we end up having you know
barry and wally west and then the the
young new 52 Wally West's al does kind
of team up and they basically defeat top
and then that's really about it but from
here this is when things really start to
focus on Wally because that's kind of
the nature of this rumor when it comes
to the to the classic Wally West the
red-haired Wally West for the most part
despite the fact that he's back in DC we
berth there hasn't really been a whole
lot of time spared to really deal with
like how he's coping with the situation
we've seen small little bits here and
there we really saw it a lot in like the
DC Universe rebirth one-shot and like
the flash aftermath story but for the
most part a lot of the stories that have
been told by DC regarding you know
classic Wally West have been told in a
way that just kind of acclimates him to
going back to the Titans getting in
contact diem with Barry Allen that kind
of a thing kind of going back to being a
superhero and it's cool because this
actually is just sort of a slow build
it's a slow burn and that's the best way
to tell stories in my book you know the
best way to tell it is to kind of let it
grow organically and when they sit down
at a taco stand while he kind of like
harkens back to you know when he was
younger and he used to come here with
iris West all the time and so it's kind
of cool because it hits back at these
small moments with his character but we
also end up finding out here is that
what Barry Allen had done is that with
the whole scenario with the top where
that battle had basically finished and
then iris West had seemingly come
running out of nowhere in order to
basically interview Wally interview
about classic Wally West we end up
finding out Barry engineered that he
didn't engineer the actions at the top
he basically tipped off iris west to
what was going on so that she would show
up and she would confront Wally and the
reason why is remember Wally's out of
time here to a degree or at least it
kind of seems that way remember when a
campus of DC rebirth the kind of
standard chronology in terms of how most
people accept it is that you had the
classic DC timeline and then you had the
Avista events of Flashpoint
and things were supposed to go back to
normal after the events of Flashpoint
but dr. Manhattan stepped in and what it
meant was that Wally West was kind of
forgotten he was sort of locked in the
Speed Force and it was a way for DC to
explain why he wasn't there and so with
classic Wally coming back for the most
part
everything's different from here you
know from the way he remembers Linda
Park doesn't remember him iris West
doesn't remember him for the most part
they don't they don't really know each
other and these are pretty big moments
because remember Linda Park was the
girlfriend of Wally West and then
eventually his wife and they had kids
together
so when Wally thinks about Linda Park
the little Park that he remembers he
remembers a family he remembers them
basically making a life for themselves
settling down that kind of a thing but
when he's thrust into this current
landscape 4dc colleagues you know none
of this stuff is going on as it was him
trying to deal with things now where he
should actually go through and talk to
Iris and reveal his identity and tell
her everything he knows where he should
go find Linda Park and even if nothing
happens basically say hey look these are
the things that I remember although that
would be kind of creepy but the bigger
picture here and the bigger gist of this
is that while he kind of takes it as an
affront now he takes it offensively for
a couple of reasons Wally's coming from
the standpoint of well Iris wouldn't be
able to handle this like if I told iris
everything this going on she wouldn't be
able to grasp it and the whole idea of
Barry is but dude like she destroyed a
Abart Thawne I promised she can handle
herself like she can handle this whole
situation but for Wally it's not that
simple and even then it's one of those
things work okay even if she could of
what business is it of yours and that
breeze in the direct you know
juxtaposition of like Wally versus Barry
the philosophical differences between
the two but it is kind of intriguing
because then this whole conversation
that they have this whole argument that
they have you know they kind of race a
little bit and then they stop you know
and Barry's like hey look man don't make
me chase you and Wally simply says look
if I wanted to run away from you there's
no way you could stop me and that's true
one thing to keep in mind this is one
the reasons why a lot of classic fans of
the flash love classic Wally West is
because when it comes down to like the
hierarchy of the fastest speedsters
Wally West is the fastest flash he's
faster than Barry Allen that's the way
this whole thing with the flash mythos
works is for a time all you had were
like these disconnected speedsters he
had like Johnny chambers and Jesse
Chambers have discovered a formula they
gave him SuperSpeed and when they said
the formula they gain their powers he
had Jay Garrick who was exposed to heavy
water or whatever it is and he inhaled
those gases and suddenly he can run at
the speed of sound and then you had max
mercury and he had all these different
characters who were able to tap into the
Speed Force it wasn't as I guess really
gain superpowers it wasn't until
terminal velocity by Mark Waid that they
were all unified that it was all hey
this formula the Johnny and Jesse
chambers say the
heavy-water whatever was that the jerk
inhaled what it did is it all allowed
them by one but one measure over another
to tap into the Speed Force and so
that's how they all gain their powers
but where Wally West is the fastest
because he directly main lines of speed
force meaning he draws directly off of
it Barry Allen was the one who made it
and so that's how all these different
characters sort of fit in so it's a
pretty cool moment when it comes down to
these characters because it's just kind
of like hey look I don't necessarily
need you anymore because remember when
it comes to cosmic Wally West when he
first became the flash Christ on
Infinite Earths happens the story ends
Wally West ages up Barry Allen's dead
and then he's you know kind of stuck
under Barry's shadow for a little while
and then under the writing of like Mark
Waid and all those guys you know it was
basically kind of taking him out of that
shadow and making him his own superhero
and so because of that Wally just kind
of grew into his own character it's
really kind of interesting with regards
to this whole like you know argument
between these two guys but the fact
remains when Wally sits down and kind of
thinks about the various people that
might might remember him work don't
really remember him per se the whole
question is who is it that we would
remember him of all the people who were
out there who would recall his existence
and he thinks back to a girl by the name
of Francis came that he grew up with now
Francis Kane was introduced back in 1982
by Marv Wolfman and George Perez and she
was a Teen Titans character the way this
whole thing worked out is much like
Chris Claremont with the x-men where he
was just like creating all different
kinds of mutants and then just throwing
him into the stories and seeing how
people responded Wolfman and Perez
during they're kind of iconic run on the
Teen Titans had done very much the exact
same thing the idea was just make it
thrown in the story send it out if fans
love it keep it if they don't get rid of
it and so what you end up having with
Francis came as she was basically a girl
who you know grew up with Wally she was
his Lana Lang so to speak those you guys
who don't know Lana Lang is basically
the girl that like first realized that
Clark Kent had powers taught him how to
use his powers and really kind of set
the stage for Clark to become Superman
later on in addition to Jonathan and
Martha Kent but the whole idea was that
she was alongside of Teen Titans for a
little while she kind of worked with the
team but ultimately ended up just kind
of walking away and there was a lot of
romance between herself and Wally West
and in fact ultimately that has kind of
ended up breaking up and going their own
separate ways but there was a point
whereby she was trying I believe she was
trying to find a way to get rid of her
powers or at least like honed her powers
of magnetism or something like that
but she ended up in countering a
scientist who kind of like twisted her
mind and then she basically developed a
split personality but that's basically
what happens here Wally shows up and
then just kind of starts talking to her
and
Hey look I don't know if you know me I
don't know if you familiar with me but
here's Who I am and and I remember you
when you were younger and that kind of a
thing and then suddenly she starts to
remember who he is now this works that
goes all the way back to DC universe
rebirth number one that's how he came
back was going to Barry Allen VL
visiting as many people as he could
anybody that knew him when he was a
superhero and then finally comes across
Barry and says you have to remember me
and at the last minute
Barry remembers him and Wally West is
back so that's kind of the the stick of
his character at the moment is he kind
of travels around to people who have
seemingly forgotten him and kind of
quote-unquote wakes up their memories
and so it is cool because basically she
recalls everything about them the fact
that they were friends the fact that
they dated for a while there was a
romance and and immediately the magenta
personality kicks in and she loses it
she just starts attacking him with
everything she can get ahold of but it
is funny and it is really intriguing
because it's him kind of having to come
back in and cope with his own demons you
know cope with the the mistakes that he
made in the past the kind of things that
he was involved in all that kind of get
stuffed
for the most part while he wants to
spill the beans in truth with her being
a villain she's really the only one he
can really confide in at the moment it
at least feels like he can confide in
Wally wes is really just a prisoner of
his own mind he's just kind of locked in
this cycle for himself you know it's not
that he went to Iris and she rebuked him
it said he's afraid to because maybe she
won't remember him and that's kind of a
fearful thing about this is that if
you're Wally West and you say okay so
like Barry Allen remembers me and like
the Titans remember me but like iris
West may not remember me that would be
the most crushing thing because that's
azan that's like one of the closest
people that he has and to suddenly find
out that she doesn't rember anything
about him Chisholm recalled him at all
it would be devastating and so it's
almost one of those things where it's
easier to just not ask than to basically
get the worst kind of answer and so what
is it happening here is where the
magenta personality begins to settle
down and while he's able to kind of talk
some sense back into Francis can sort of
bring that persona back out this brings
her character back and so it really kind
of teases the possibility that things
could go one of two ways if Wally has to
choose between Linda Park and Francis
Kane which one will he choose now
depending on where you stand with the
flash comics you could go either way
there are people who are classic fans
are like nope I want to see him marry
Linda Park and I want to see them have
giant iris West and I want to see them
like his younger kids feel and I want to
see them be like a flash family again
you know classic Wally West fans would
love to
that come back but then some people are
kind of like yeah but I mean like we've
done that dance before and so that's
what people are kind of curious about
they're like well if we got Francis
Caine that changes everything because
now Wally West has to do with a
girlfriend whose craziest help but like
it's also a chick he dated at one point
along the line so what you end up having
is Wally sort of coming to grips with
things you know is Wally basically
saying look to this point in my life I
have been in the situation where I am in
this you know this this rebirth
landscape it's not the place that I
remember and I've effectively kind of
kept myself shunted off I've used the
events of like fighting alongside the
Titans I've used the events of fighting
alongside the flash to effectively shy
away from that part of my life and avoid
it all and so what he needs to do at
least you know from his wrist
perspective is to basically sit down and
say I have to come to grips with where I
am right now
I have to come to grips with like where
my life is at the moment the longer he
goes without talking to Linda Park the
least likely the opportunity is they'll
ever get together because we're talking
about you know something legitimate
she'll just find a guy and eventually
settle down but if Wally West steps in
and says hey look you know let's get a
cup of coffee I'm ready to talk to you
about something and I know it's gonna
sound crazy as hell but hear me out if
it sparks memories extreme members who
he is suddenly everything comes rolling
back in again that's the risk is it's
kind of like this in comic book
adaptation of the nature of love sure
ask your girl out get your heart broken
and that happens a thousand times but
then you ask a girl out she says yes and
you're married four years later so you
know it's one of those things where it's
just kind of like you never know how
it's gonna work out you just got to give
it a shot you got to throw it out there
and just kind of see what happens and so
where he ultimately kind of you know
goes back to his position and really
kind of says look I got to go back with
a flash family you know I'm as much a
part of this as Barry Allen as anybody
else we end up jumping back to the 25th
century and as we go through this we end
up finding out that again this guy is
basically going through in tastin a
group called the Renegades we're just
kind of like the 25th century version of
like the Rogues
you've got guys like mirror monarch and
Commander Colt but where that group is
tasked with going back and essentially
capturing Barry Allen what we end up
finding out is this group has actually
been sent back by hunter zolomon and
this is cool this is really interesting
because as far as I'm aware we have not
seen hunter zolomon yet in DC rebirth
and this begs the question are we gonna
go with like his old-school origin where
he's basically almost identical to be
Rihanna in the sense that his parents
you know never really well
it's personal his parents never got
along Barry Allen's parents got along
fine okay so not exactly like Barry but
Hunter's parents didn't really get along
too well it turned out his father was a
serial killer as his mom
gonna turn him in the father hunter
killed his mom and then he was arrested
I guess he was really killed by the cops
when everything popped off and he
refused to surrender and then basically
had his legs broken and then you know I
guess you know was paralyzed and then
broke into like the flash Museum and
tried to use a cosmic treadmill and then
like it displaced him from the time from
the timeline we might just do like a
hunter zolomon explained video or
something along those lines an
anticipation for flash war I don't know
but if you guys are near here to
comments explain it make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]